Mathieu vous allez voir un indice car ce
rideau vous conserveau
est-ce que j'ai pas été prendre un verre
avec les poteaux de la BAC
à la personne qui est venue pour vous
qui est venu pour moi
bonsoir
c'est ton père Monsieur
est-ce que tu reconnais cette personne
tu es tout je n'ai jamais vu cette
personne de ma vie et je pense qu'elle
doit confondre également
pourquoi vous êtes là pourquoi je suis
là ouais alors je suis là pour retirer
un véhicule mal stationné
il est où ce véhicule est-ce qu'on peut
voir le véhicule
alors stationnement gênant à chaque fois
que Monsieur Delormeau est là
stationnement gênant et bien votre
voiture
alors oui mais
il y a le symbole il y a un petit
macaron dessus
c'est ma voiture oui je regarde toujours
devant parce que c'est moins loin pour
repartir alors justement
c'est interdit et c'est interdit
un peu la gueule à Factory quand même
non parce qu'en fait des gens pour la
sécurité
des pompiers tout ça donc ils ont décidé
aujourd'hui de t'enlever ta voiture
une question de sécurité
donc je vois pas comment point l'enlever
aujourd'hui
combien combien vous voulez pour 135
euros je libère le véhicule bah oui
que tu as 100 %
elle était très bien garée c'est du
raquette
il est devant il est mal garé hein
c'est un coup de fil d'Hermann pour moi
c'est 2 minutes si vous voulez Bernard
[Applaudissements]
le plus riche
pour toi
Gérald Darmanin qui sera notre invité
dans face à maman on dirait que
t'inquiète pas
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je peux faire une proposition
à Jacques oui
on fait un selfie couleur avec ton
téléphone c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
c'est ça exactement
espèce uniquement ce soir
ça serait bien gentil alors je vais vous
dire la vérité j'avais tout prévu j'ai
ici
c'est quand je me gare devant la
poubelle Jacques que ça vous agace
là-bas entre nous agace exactement ouais
c'est là-bas ouais ouais c'est ça
franchement j'aime pas tellement hein
vous êtes vraiment
Mathieu Jacques vous saviez que c'était
Mathieu Delormeau ou pas ouais tout à
fait ouais vous l'aimez pas du tout oh
pas spécialement non
[Applaudissements]
voilà si ça m'était un autre une autre
personne vous l'auriez enlevé la voiture
peut-être pas si ça avait été si ça
avait été Géraldine maillet à voir
vraiment vraiment
[Rires]
tous les deux après quelque chose il y a
une sorte de juriste prudence quand on
est connu c'est vrai qu'on peut les
voies de bus ben oui vraiment
c'est quand on est cocu
[Applaudissements]
ça se passait très bien Mathieu ouais
tu as de la chance il va falloir quelque
chose c'est-à-dire que je vous donne les
135 € vous allez devoir faire des
compliments à Béatrice Rosen qui nous
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je garde les enfants
[Applaudissements]
tournent toi ta voiture que tu arrives
les portes s'ouvrent tu as ton petit
parking
[Musique]
on en est pas oui
est-ce que vous voulez que Mathieu
Delormeau se fasse enlever sa voiture
[Applaudissements]
et en plus je n'ai pas le droit
[Musique]
merci Mathieu et à prévoir à prévoir une
batterie parce que les clignotants
c'était à ton alarme ça après avoir une
balle Gémeaux j'ai même pas le droit de
prendre le métro
parce qu'il y a des bactéries des
machins
[Applaudissements]
ça m'amuse
j'avais l'argent
[Applaudissements]
change la vie parce que c'est vrai qu'il
va falloir toujours je regarde toujours
mal devant c'est le petit côté je suis
pas comme vous il abuse un petit côté
rebelle c'est sérieux
là c'est 135
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]